what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with basically Kane the
Conqueror now this is a story called
Timeless this is a one shot and this is
amazing because Kane the Conqueror is
gonna fight Doctor Doom and it's one of
the coolest things ever all right so
check this out so this story is written
from the perspective of a guy named
Anatoly Petrov and this guy is basically
in the present day because we're gonna
actually have some multiversal hijinks
not really traditional time travel
hijinks we will to a degree but what
this guy's doing is literally
chronicling the stories of different
villains who have existed across the
world and what he ends up saying here or
the way he kind of lines it out is that
going pound for pound looking at
accomplishment versus accomplishment
that the greatest threat the Earth has
ever faced when it came to various
villains was actually Doctor Doom that
it was Dr Doom who was the greatest
threat no matter where you go now this
actually lines up really really well
with the story that we're covering over
on Thursdays which should come out
tomorrow which is Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four where even he establishes
that Dr Doom and every universe is the
greatest threat that universe is ever
going to face because his desire for
power is Limitless and he will capture
incredibly high levels of power right
his thirst is just unquenchable and so
ultimately Kang ends up visiting Dr
Petrov now some of this is just sort of
Kang being petty where he wants to prove
that he's actually better than Dr Doom
which is pretty straightforward but it's
one of those things it's one of those
interesting kind of situations because
Petrov asked him like are you here to
kill me and the response of Kang is no
right I'm here to show you or to do what
nobody else can do I'm here to change
your mind right I'm here to get you to
see me differently than the way that
you've seen me based on my different
hijinks and so on now that's an
important distinction to understand and
the reason why is because when it comes
to someone like Doctor Doom he's in
latviria right so he's literally right
over there you can just go see him over
there if you are foolish enough to do so
with King the Conqueror he exists in the
future of the 31st Century which unless
you're the Fantastic Four or you you're
some person or group of people out there
with the ability to time travel you
don't really know King all you know is
Kang when he appears and does some
things now an argument could be made if
you wanted to be seen as more than what
he was then he should have just not been
a dick every time he showed up but still
like that's that's kind of the argument
that's being created here right and so
this guy being able to actually travel
along with King the Conqueror in his
various conquests and whatnot basically
gives him a much better understanding of
who Kang is about and so what this does
is it actually has him has Kang bringing
Petrov back to the early days of
humanity where he ends up fighting this
just gigantic woolly mammoth now the
funny thing about this and this is one
of the cool things when it comes to Kang
he is arguably one of the more powerful
members in Marvel Comics in terms of
what he can just do on his own which is
to say his fighting style or his powers
he's not really much of a challenge to
anybody what makes Kings so dangerous is
his ability to manipulate time he he can
just go back in time and prevent you
from being born and so in the face of
the fact that a guy can prevent your
existence from happening again he kind
of Falls in that threshold of being one
of the more powerful characters more or
less because of what his technology
allows him to do and less so what he's
physically capable of doing but even
then when it comes to Kane despite all
that vaunted ability what he prefers to
do is challenge himself on the personal
level and that's why in facing off
against this woolly mammoth he literally
just casts aside all this technology all
of his arms all of his Armament and then
decides to fight this thing with nothing
but a knife now this is designed to show
Dr Petrov what Kings capable of in
one-on-one conflict which admittedly is
actually something Doctor Doom can't do
a lot of you guys don't know that Dr
Doom is not an accomplished fighter Dr
Doom is a guy who uses magic and
mysticism but when it comes to just
full-on one-to-one man-to-man bare
knuckle fighting Dr Doom doesn't really
have it right like it's just not
necessarily there every time he faced
off again against the Incredible Hulk or
overpowered The Incredible Hulk or
something like that it was one of those
things where it was largely relegated to
him using some sort of magic or
mysticism in order to subscribe to this
YouTube channel which is what you should
be doing right now make sure you guys
hit the Subscribe button but in all
seriousness in order to achieve his goal
and so once this battle is done right
once this conflict is over and of course
you have Kang who's basically up on top
and he's the guy who's kind of you know
the the winner so to speak that what he
ends up doing is taking Dr Petrov back
to his vessel and then suddenly they end
up getting a chronal anomaly detection
basically it's like an earthquake right
something in the timeline is being
disrupted now this is one of the things
that Kang is always aware of right if
scientists always have these kind of
seismographs around the world in order
to determine when an earthquake is
happening then King has those all across
the time stream to know when someone's
traveling back and forth through time
now sometimes he'll do nothing it just
doesn't matter other times he'll
teleport there and he'll just watch and
he'll see how things unfold and then
there's times when he'll actually step
in and intervene this is one of those
times when he steps in and intervenes
now the cool thing about this is that
the way the king describes it is that
it's basically a Time Quake right that
something is exerting extreme chronal
gravity Upon Our timeline so here's
something that I want you guys to be
aware of right anytime you've ever
watched a a science film and there's
something like the Moon that crashes
into Earth during that garbage ass movie
moonfall or when you had like uh
Melancholia which is actually a
phenomenal movie and you basically have
some giant Celestial body that crashes
into Earth it doesn't work that way what
you actually have is something called
the Roche limit so quite literally if a
planet twice the size of Earth got close
enough the gravity of that planet would
actually start tearing chunks of the
earth apart until eventually the two
crashed into each other but it would be
that Celestial body crashing into what
remains of like a third of the Earth or
something along those lines that's
basically what's happening here that
this alternate reality is moving closer
and closer to the main Marvel Universe
and as it does it's quite literally
enacting the Roche limit which is
pulling the timeline apart that was
starting as kind of things on the
fringes of the universe itself just way
way out there where no one's going to
notice like an army that's creeping up
from 200 miles away but eventually it'll
get close enough to where everybody will
notice and then when it reaches that
point it will simply be too late and so
what ends up happening is Kang brings Dr
Petrov with him and they teleport to
this universe right they teleport to
this reality now one of the cool things
that goes on here is this story does
take place before a lot of the things
that we've read so far Avengers versus
X-Men versus eternals and so on and so
forth but one of the other things that
it does is it continues to tease the
upcoming Thanos story now for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
the upcoming Thanos story is a story
where Thanos gets the Infinity Stones
attaches them to the Hammer of mjolnir
that belongs to Thor which Thanos is
wielding he's also got the arm of the
Destroyer armor and he's leading an army
of the Dead God only knows what in the
hell happened to get to that point but
we will find out and I am excited so
here's the thing the way the king
describes this alternate reality is a
pirate timeline and the reality here is
that it's not supposed to be here so
what he ends up doing is actually giving
Dr Petrov this bit of an explanation
about the nature of immortus so for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Marvel Comics bear with me here because
I'm sure we're gonna have people who
don't know anything about Kang or
immortus or whatever so I'm going to
explain that to them here so for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with this
and to to explain this in ridiculously
simplified terms immortus is the end
result of Kang and it follows a linear
progression right so in the 31st Century
Nathaniel Richard supposedly the
descendant of Doctor Doom ends up
discovering he can travel through time
the first thing he does is he goes back
to his younger self and he tells him
these are the decisions you need to make
so that you become me basically King the
Conqueror his younger self chooses to
Rebel he becomes iron lad the next thing
came conqueror does is he travels to the
distant past on Earth in Egypt and he
tries to conquer the world in Ancient
Egypt he calls himself Rama Tut he's
defeated by The Fantastic Four he's
supposed to go back to the 31st Century
but instead he discovers true limbo
which is a place that exists outside of
space and time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you refer to that place as the
quantum realm inside of limbo King
realizes that he's part of the bigger
Multiverse as a whole but also the
Multiverse has a very delicate balance
and so what he ends up doing is
basically striking a deal with the
timekeepers in that as immortus which is
what he calls himself now that he will
basically prune the timeline of any
alternate realities that are decaying or
dying or aren't supposed to be there
whatever the case happens to be using
whatever Rhyme or Reason makes sense to
Marvel Comics at the time it's literally
just that there's really nothing more to
it than that and so every time you pick
up a Marvel comic and you see King the
Conqueror like in this story this is
taking place between the time when
Nathaniel Richards discovered time
travel in the 31st Century but before he
traveled to limbo and became immortus
that's basically when these things are
taking place hopefully that makes sense
let's get back into it so here's the
thing once this is kind of discussed the
idea behind it is that this timeline was
supposed to have been destroyed this
timeline was supposed to have just kind
of been set adrift and so what a mortise
would do is much like a dead flower or a
dead leaf on a tree he would prune it
meaning he would clip the branch and
when that happened it would basically
just drift off into the ether it's
supposed to effectively just disappear
right just kind of go into what is the
black hole of existence but something
happened in this universe where it
didn't instead of quote unquote falling
to the ground and dying it actually
started to pull itself back to the tree
or in this instance the main timeline
something is doing that and so that's
what Kang and Dr Petrov are going to
investigate now once they get there the
first thing they see and this is what's
so crazy about this the first thing they
end up seeing are all these dead
celestials right like all these dead
celestials everywhere and in fact the
sort of Damocles which was at one point
the base of Kane the Conqueror
presumably in this alternate reality
that's destroyed as well but whatever
this being is or whoever this person is
is able to destroy Cosmic entities
literally crush them and defeat them
which is no small feat that's colossal
right but this also indicates this
person can basically control the
fundamental forces of reality because it
looks like it was a hand-to-hand fight
where these guys were killed and so as
you end up having Kang and Dr Petrov who
enter into the Sword of Damocles and
make their way throughout this entire
Citadel they ultimately end up coming
across Doctor Doom now this is the crazy
thing here right like this is this is
the crazy thing it's not just Doctor
Doom right like he's like he's like I
have come Victor it's not just Doctor
Doom instead it's actually this Doctor
Doom who references not just Kang but a
king so what this seems to indicate is
more than one king the Conqueror has
traveled to this place and try tried to
destroy this guy because remember every
Universe in the Multiverse has its own
version of King the Conqueror so
different versions of Kang have
discovered that this universe is trying
to get back to the Multiverse and is
tearing apart timelines on its journey
and so they've come here trying to
defeat Doctor Doom and were probably
destroyed in in return and that's that
either that or he just destroyed his own
universe as king and this is like the
second one he's met I don't know but
regardless of the situation what we end
up finding out here is that once this
version of Doctor Doom removes his
helmet that is not actually Victor Von
Doom this guy is Reed Richards that what
he had done is that in this alternate
universe when it had basically been
plucked from the timeline that null time
or basically the destruction of the
universe itself has started to creep in
right literally the universe started
falling apart at the seams the different
superheroes banded together and the
different superheroes were able to Stave
off their own destruction the problem
with this is that all it did was
basically slow things down there was no
way to stop the destruction of this
universe as time went on because of the
fact that it's just kind of existing out
there and is going to be eaten or or
kind of consumed or destroyed not really
by like a physical being out there it's
simply just it's it's you existing out
in the desert for like you know 60 days
with no water right you're gonna die
long before you reach those 60 days
you'll die of dehydration and that's
literally what this what what happened
with this universe and so what ended up
going on here is this version of read
literally says the world was still sick
right still dying the entropic death of
our timeline was still occurring just an
inch at a time the world lost hope do
you know what happens to a society
without hope King total collapse and he
says I never lost hope not for the world
the trade-off is that I threw away any
hope for myself I would do anything to
save the world so I replaced my eyes
with the time and reality stones and
forced my will upon the timeline I
killed celestials and drank their blood
to take their power for myself I
destroyed anyone who raised a hand
raised even their voice against me and
my mission my mission to save this
timeline so quite literally what Reed
Richards in this alternate reality did
is he killed Dr Doom he took his place
he took the time in the reality Stones
now he basically has the ability to
control all of time and space then he
killed the celestials and consumed their
power and so it's basically one of the
most powerful versions of Doctor Doom
that we've ever seen in Marvel Comics
the only two versions I would say that
are more powerful than this one is the
version of Doctor Doom that got The
full-on Infinity Gauntlet in an
alternate reality story and the version
of Doctor Doom that basically took the
power of the beyonder in the original
Secret Wars from 1984 a playlist that
you will find down in the description
which you are welcome to check out after
you're done with this video but the
thing about this is that as time
progresses right as this kind of
conversation goes on you end up
basically having Kane the Conqueror
launching his attacks against Dr Doom as
best he can but the funny thing about
this is that at the end of the day none
of it really seems to work and the
reason why is because with Dr Doom
controlling all of time and space and
with them being in an alternate reality
what Kang had done is he had brought all
of his arms and Armament with him he'd
brought all of his weapons with him and
he basically just kind of stored them
just slightly out of phase with the
existing Universe right so basically
like a second ahead so we can just kind
of reach and grab those and then come
back because remember with somebody like
hang who time travels for you and me it
might look like teleportation for for
Kane the Conqueror he teleported away at
five minutes to and then traveled ten
thousand years into the future and then
when he came back it was five minutes
and one second right that's how it would
look that's how it would be for king
that's what it's like when you can
basically control time so again it's a
pretty badass moment but the reality
here is realizing what Kang's doing and
because he controls time and reality
what Reid ends up doing is that actually
teleporting all of Kang's weapons to its
location and then basically destroying
all the weapons of Kang save for his own
sword and so again it's kind of
hearkening back to the beginning of the
story where Kang was facing off against
this giant woolly mammoth monster using
nothing but a knife but something that I
want you guys to notice here is that in
this fight against Doom where Kang is
just hopelessly outmatched to be quite
honest with you guys where he simply
just cannot be destroyed by Kang because
he's just way more powerful in terms of
all the energy that he has Anatoly
starts to see Kane the Conqueror in a
way that he just hadn't really seen
before and a lot of this is the writer
Jed McKay kind of really giving us this
change in perspective of King in the
sense that when you look at things like
the Fantastic Four where he shows up and
faces off against them or in Young
Avengers or even the Avengers Comics
themselves most appearances of Kane the
Conqueror are just him as some kind of a
demigod right just some kind of an
astronomical being who's just doing
crazy things and manipulating time and
trying to find some way to conquer the
world depending on what story you're
reading he feels like a villain of the
week but something that's going on here
and it's not even just Jed McKay doing
this it's Marvel in general they're
doing a lot more of these kind of deep
dives into the nature of King as opposed
to him just being a guy who fights The
Avengers manipulates time assumes or
assembles a giant you know Council of
himself that there's a lot more to him
than that and so where people have
looked at Kang and they've seen him as
almost a god-like entity this man that
manipulates and controls time that for
King himself Nathaniel doesn't see
himself that way he doesn't see himself
as some kind of a Godly being who's
Beyond reproach or anything like that
and in fact he's actually relishing this
conflict he's loving the idea that in
this fight against Dr Doom that he could
be killed that he could be destroyed by
this guy he just loves this opportunity
and he's just kind of living for this
moment but at the end of the day one of
the cool things he points out and really
just kind of gets into the mind of read
is he taunts him with the idea that he
was always going to be a tyrant now this
is an indication of how well Kane the
Conqueror her knows Reed Richards versus
how well he knows Victor Von Doom right
Reed Richards being Mr Fantastic the
leader of the Fantastic Four he's always
calm he's always composed but when we
look at stories like Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four Reed Richards forming the
Council of reads and then screwing
things up when we look at things like
Civil War or we look at the formation of
the Illuminati or even when you go into
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers run and Reed has to come to the
realization that he can't save the
Multiverse and that seemingly this kind
of falls on his shoulders at least from
his perspective it's very easy for him
to be emotionally manipulated mentally
not so much because for the most part
Reed's just too smart for that but
toying where there's emotions getting
him to think out of being logical and
more emotional that's not difficult for
Kane to do it's difficult for most
anybody else to do but it's not
difficult for Kane because he knows The
Life and Times of read the thing about
this is that as these guys are talking
and as they're progressing and sort of
doing their thing that what happens is
that in that moment when literally Reed
is about to kill Kang that Anatoly kind
of shows up out of nowhere steals one of
the weapons that belongs to Reed himself
the one that he used to basically kill
most everybody there and then kills Reed
with his own Spear and so in that moment
there's this kind of conversation that
happens between the two of them because
the funny thing about this is that King
responds and says you would Aid the
Conqueror in single combat you
understands what this means do you not
and the response of Anatoly is I know I
know that you'll kill me for it and so
King responds and says then why why
would you do such a thing Court to death
you know I must dispense and the
response of Anatoly here is incredibly
insightful right he says if Doom
Richards killed you I would be dead
anyway and my timeline would be at risk
do you believe to be the Pinnacle of
humanity you must be greater than all
others you must put yourself before all
others but I believe that true human
greatness lies in putting others before
you yourself and so Kang kind of
overhears this and then just sort of
laughs at him right and then walks away
right of course he ends up ringing and
it's holy back but one of the things he
says is he says come on I believe our
time together is finished I will return
you to shortly after we left your office
and the response here where anatoly's
kind of like okay this is strange like I
thought my death was impending Kang
actually responds in a really
interesting way he says this is still my
victory I brought you with me as another
of my weapons Petrov Richards Doom the
one thing you can count on from them is
their arrogance this was all to plan but
you of course don't know that this is
the very reason I take on traveling
companions Petrov I like being
challenged you stood up to me knowing
that I would most likely kill you that
is the kind of Courage I have always
admired in humanity that is the element
that makes our species worthy that is
what Humanity possesses that has allowed
it to produce King and that's the cool
thing right that's the interesting thing
about Nathaniel Richards again when you
look at Kang from a different
perspective it's kind of hard to see him
as a guy where he's more than just some
dude who jumps back and forth through
time and causes problems but in this
moment here right now as he's talking to
Anatoly it's like I can respect those
who would look in the face of death and
laugh who would even challenge those who
are greater than them to me there is
nothing better among Humanity than a
person who looks to to basically become
better than who they are that's how I
got to where I am and that's what makes
Humanity great most people will never do
that 99 of people will fall Rank and
file and they'll live the life they live
because that's just what you're supposed
to do they'll never think outside the
box but for those who do they go on to
become great people and do great things
you're one of those people Petrov also
just be aware if you write your book and
you talk about how Doom's the greatest
villain of all time and not me I'm gonna
come back and kill you so just put my
name in there instead of Doom which is
really Kang in his most True Form but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace